make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting into Secret Wars
too here's the cool thing this story is
only nine issues along and technically
we can cover it in two parts right it's
nowhere near as complex as Secret Wars
one the interesting thing about this is
depending on who you talk to some people
will say they hated Secret Wars too
now the people will say it was amazing
it's so pretty well from what I
understand so I enjoyed it like I enjoy
the second half of it the first half is
kind of like alright but the second half
is when you get like the cosmic entities
and all that kind of crazy stuff which
gets really really cool but nonetheless
picking up with this again this really
kind of comes hot off the heels not not
immediately but it comes off the heels
of the the first Secret Wars comic right
so we're talking about the idea that at
the end of the first Secret Wars the
idea of the Beyonder was never fully
reconciled in the sense that we never
really knew what it was we somebody just
knew he was just this entity that was
like I am from beyond and that was
basically it but because the the story
sold so well indicating people liked it
otherwise people wouldn't have bought it
because you know people don't buy
stories they don't like the result is
that Marvel continued the song into a
second comic now this one really picks
up with Owen Reese and Marsha now if
those you guys who saw Secret Wars one
you'll recall those two why they kind of
have that that story really focus on
their relationship and ultimately Owen
Reese ended up moving in with Marsha in
Denver Colorado right so that is kind of
relaxing and chilling and doing their
thing when there's like this huge you
know kind of explosion sound from off in
the distance now the funny thing about
this is that you know and Reese is like
I don't know maybe it was a truck that
backfired or something like that and
it's like okay look Owen if that was a
truck that backfired you see the biggest
truck in the history of the world or it
exploded because like it's pretty far
away and it's a pretty loud noise but at
that point the entire TV starts going on
the fritz the signals lost all kinds of
crazy things are going on and when they
stick their head out and they start
looking at what's going on suddenly like
all these trees and huge chunks of rocks
and everything are all flying in a
direction now Marcia is able to destroy
one of the boulders but a response Owen
Reese of course uses his powers to kind
of you know really kind of seem to try
to control the situation but what he
ends up realizing is that on one of
these chunks of rock is a guy out there
right just some guy sitting on this rock
and Owen Reese begins to pick up on the
energy signature and realizes it's the
Beyonder now when that happens we
immediately switch over to Charles
Xavier
there's a couple things that I want to
talk about here and really one big thing
that I want to discuss the first thing
is that this comes before uncanny x-men
issue number 200 right so at this point
in time Charles Xavier is still here on
earth and magneto has not taken over
leadership of the x-men
the New Mutants but he's on his way to
taking over that role that's the reason
why when you actually see magneto in
this story he'll have that outfit with a
great big huge M on it and it'll look
like the cover of uncanny x-men where
he's standing there in handcuffs
handcuffs on his on his hands and on his
feet where he's basically going to stand
trial right the trial of magneto is what
that story was called that's why it
looks so familiar here but the other
part of this is that on the x-men roster
is Rachel summers now the idea of Rachel
summers for those of us who are familiar
with her character bear with me for a
second this is not a huge talking point
but she is going to be more or less the
field commander of the team at least in
this particular instance given the power
that she possesses but the reason why
this matters is Rachel summers made her
debut in Days of Future past what you
guys have all pretty much heard of that
story and she was essentially the only
instance in any alternate reality where
we've ever seen Scott Summers or Cyclops
in jean grey have a child and it turned
out to be a girl right in every other
alternate reality it's a guy it's
basically Nate Nate grey or Nate summers
whatever you want to call him rachel is
the only exception to that at least that
I know of the result is that during Days
of Future past of course she said the
mine of Kitty Pryde into the past to
stop the assassination of Charles Xavier
more McTaggart and Senator Robert Kelley
in order to prevent Days of Future past
in happening the result is that it
didn't quite work out that way and so
what ended up happening is that while
Days of Future past was stopped the
future that Rachel came from became an
alternate reality and so what she ended
up doing was basically traveling back
into the past and really kind of
arriving in the modern day now this
takes place in a few different stories
it's really kind of spread over days of
future present from the 1990s xcalibur
number 52 and uncanny x-men number 199
now uncanny x-men 199 is really where
it's kind of like here she is now but
the idea is that she kind of has a
fraction of the Phoenix forces powers up
which she attained from the Days of
Future past time when she basically got
it from that at that point and then jump
back to the modern day but that's why
she's essentially here now right now
he's a future president focuses more on
Franklin that alternate reality is
really the spiritual essence of Franklin
Richards from Days of Future past
showing up and then you know all kinds
of crazy stuff happening but that's more
or less how rachel gets here but over
the course of those three stories and
some ancillary stories in between it's
all kind of fleshed out right but that's
basically why she's here you can kind of
take that and run with it you know and
just just sort of sort of go with it
but at the end of the day what Xavier
does before he kind of passes out from
the mental strain is basically soon this
kind of telepathic message out to a
whole bunch of the different Avengers
right Captain America a magneto a few
others you know basically say the
Beyonder is back now right
beyonders arrived here on earth and even
Western America now from that point it
basically switches back over to Owen
this is where things get kind of cool is
because when the Beyonder arrives here
he's actually in amalgamated of a bunch
of different characters right he's an
amalgamation of kind of like Ben Graham
and dr. doom and Cyclops and ulysses
klaw and so on and so forth and he
basically just like he literally looks
like a 1980s wrestler more or less like
the WWF in the 1980s like here comes the
Beyonder with dink and do you know who's
gonna win the match but uh but that's
that's kind of how it looks but but
notice this any symbols of humanity is
essentially removed now that's something
that I want you to focus on because that
was one of the cool aspects of secret
Wars 2 is the Beyonder progressively
becomes more human over the course of
the story but all he basically says is I
desire to understand now Owen Reese is
aware of who the Beyonder is right like
what he's capable of so he doesn't
really need a whole lot of explanation
here but the overall reason for why the
be honours doing this or why he's here
is because remember like in the first
secret wars he looked at humanity right
he looked at the overall gist of
humanity and basically said that there
is essentially incompleteness there now
this incompleteness is a result of
people right like the nature of human
beings in the sense that in the beyond
diverse at the time this story was
written the Beyonder was essentially his
entire universe right so there was
nothing but him whereas here you've got
all different kinds of organisms and
people and races and things like that
you've got political conflicts and
you've got different ideologies and so
on and so forth
but everybody's looking to understand
the meaning of life which is really what
the Beyonder is asking here and so the
result is that owners like man I can't
really answer that question I can't
really answer the question of what the
meaning of life is instead he gives them
a little bit of guidance and it's really
more to just kind of get him out of his
hair and he's like the only way to
really understand the the meaning of
life is to gain experience to go out
there and experience things and then
kind of figure it out for yourself right
into a degree that's true right you know
confidence comes with experience
understanding the world it comes with
experience but you got to get out there
you got to try things and you got to see
what kind of works for you what doesn't
and then just go from there and so with
the beyond are basically taking off of
course Marsha asked the question is
everything gonna be okay and Owens like
yeah man he'll be fine he's just some
omnipotent being that doesn't understand
humanity and he just kind of floating
out there in the world what's the worst
that could happen but from there you
basically pick up with the x-men more or
less meeting up with magneto right now
this is kind of a skirmish that sort of
pops off it's on a great big huge thing
it's like one page more or less but
essentially Colossus
to the rescue and it's like hey look
Magneto's here to talk right he's here
to talk to us he's not really here to
initiate a conflict or anything like
that everything's cool chill out guys
like it's all gonna be alright so of
course they ain't no grabbing a vehicle
and then traveling out to Hollywood
where they're beyond a resides now one
thing to understand is that Rachel
summers is kind of the connection there
right she can pick up on where the
beyonders at because of her telepathic
powers but she's by no means on par with
the beyond right she doesn't really have
the same kind of power that he does
instead what you would end up getting is
basically the beyond are showing up in
Los Angeles and then coming across a guy
by the name of Stuart cadwal now this is
kind of important here because the
beyond er doesn't really understand the
notion of good and evil right it doesn't
easily understand what good is what evil
is he does understand human desire he
doesn't understand things like being
taken advantage of or anything along
those lines I said when when he
basically displays his power to Stuart
and turning like his office and
everything into like just a whole bunch
of apples release his desk and
everything and do a whole bunch of
apples then it's her and Stuart picks up
on the idea of this guy can do anything
so he basically says give me a fraction
of your power and then what kind of go
from there and so what is up happening
is the Beyonder bestows a fraction of
its power on to Stewart and Stewart goes
forward as like this this guy named
Thunder sword now this is where things
get a little murky because you would
think that the Beyonder would have
learned his lesson from the first secret
wars but stowing his power onto somebody
and how awful it can go awry we've kind
of seen how that can play out and how
negative that can be especially with dr.
doom having stolen his power in the
first place so Alyssa the Beyonder
hasn't learned anything from his first
and first experience with humanity in
the various superheroes but what the
students up doing is it basically leads
to Stuart kind of going forward as
Thunder Lord and trying to like make the
world a better place but ultimately
causing more problems than anything else
attacking various places and any any
ideology that he doesn't agree with he
ends up attacking right so it's like
Twitter basically and the result is that
when this happens of course the x-men
who are hot on the trail of the Beyonder
stumble across this great big huge
conflict and then basically try to track
down Thunder Lord and defeat him and at
the same time the Avengers respond as
well so it's not particularly
interesting and it's not really really
fascinating what is kind of important
here is what goes on behind the scenes
and this will be a common theme that you
will see with regards to the first you
don't really this video is like
something will be happening and then the
Beyonder will just pop up and the reason
for that is because unlike the first
secret Wars which was entirely
self-contained it was just a 12 issued
limited series and even have really have
to read anything else because it took
place out in you know out in space on
battle world with super Wars - it
actually ties in the
going come try and we'll talk about that
you know as we kind of get through this
we won't go into the individual comics
themselves but what kind of talk about
that to a degree but what is up
happening is that while thunderlord's
kind of running amok and doing his whole
thing you basically have the Beyonder
who appears to to Rachel summers and
then to Illyana Rasputin and when he
does he basically takes the Darkchild
concept of Illyana Rasputin where she
gives in to this kind of inner evil and
then just grabs her like literally
seizes her forces the Darkchild person
off personality to manifest and then in
turn the dark child whisks them away to
limbo right so it's kind of a way to
sort of remove the x-men temporarily to
kind of follow up in their own
individual comic and then of course they
end up returning here but Wolverine
basically lashes out kind of goes into a
berserker rage believing that the
Beyonder he basically killed them and
when that happens what is up going on as
a Beyonder of course slashed all the
pieces and bleeding all over the place
is perfectly fine and then basically the
x-men are just kind of made to vanish
right there's sort of like okay you're
out of here now understand the Beyonder
is not doing this because it's like I
feel like doing evil things because I
saw a really mean TV show and I'm just
copying what I saw that's not the case
for him there he's just doing things
right like for him it's no different
than breathing or anything like that but
what he's doing is experimenting and
learning that's essentially what's
happening here right so it's no
different than a baby coming to the
realization that if it cries it will get
attention a baby can't say my diaper
needs to be changed the baby just cries
and then the parents come to it and then
basically you know solve whatever is
ailing that baby at that point in time
but so of course thunderlord is more or
less taken out you know pretty quickly
in the sense that it's like okay you
know is his powers are basically drain
and the molecule man just sort of leaves
him there and walks away but in response
to that where he sort of vanishes you
know Captain America tries to confront
him and he kind of vanishes instead a
kind of facsimile of the Beyonder in an
invisible form follows Captain America
around just to see what's going on but
at the same time he also teleports his
main self directly to the city of New
York and then actually ends up in San
Francisco and then just starts looking
around and in like taking a look at
people and just sort of seeing what's
going on and what you get is this sort
of run over about different things that
are taking place in the various comics
right like this coincides around within
about a month or two a Fantastic Four
issue number 280 those are guys who
understand that who know that reference
you get the significance of it those are
guys who don't that's basically the
beginning of the malleus saga where
Susan storm becomes malice is about
three or four issues along though she
becomes like this totally evil version
of herself more or less but what's also
going on
this is kind of an on running theme in
the the fantastic four stories up to
this point is you basically have psycho
man now psycho man is not particularly
important he's not very interesting at
all he's a character that's been around
for a long time right since about 1967
and he actually comes from the
Microverse right the microscopic
universe inside the main Marvel Universe
and the Marvel Cinematic Universe they
called the quantum realm is basically
what it is but it's all essentially the
same thing they call it that because
Marvel doesn't have the legal rights to
use the Microverse outside of the comics
as far as I'm aware but essentially
psycho-man and then you've also got hate
monger
it's weird ah they're basically kind of
going through and just instilling hate
you know every breeze every place they
go manipulating the emotions of people
and driving them into conflict against
superheroes but ultimately you end up
having psycho man I just really hate
monger and psycho man using their mecha
nations to turn Susan storm into malice
and that kind of continues on in the
actual Fantastic Four to 82 to 83 but
what you also have going on here if
somebody grabs a brick throws it through
the window of a department building and
the Beyonder walks in and as this guy
walks up and it's just like did you
throw the brick through the window and
you know why are you working in here the
response to the Beyonder is I just
desire to learn right I just
itis the desire to understand most of
the guys like look I don't know who you
are or what's going on but it's kind of
weird that your dress on and white with
no shoes on but maybe you should go find
a friend and so at the end of the day
the Beyonder is like okay yes I will do
that I will go find a friend and then
ultimately seeks out Peter Parker now
Peter Parker doesn't realize it's the
Beyonder in the beyond or doesn't tell
him who he is now it's really more
because of the fact that it doesn't dawn
on him to introduce himself he's just
kind of like I am from beyond you know
or something along those lines but
ultimately it gets kind of crazy because
the Beyonder looks at Peter Parker and
sees that when he's just Peter that
people just kind of treat him like a
normal person but when he puts on the
spider-man costume suddenly everybody's
like oh my god it's spider-man mystery
starts asking things like you know why
do people eat you know why do people do
these kinds of things right having
watched what people do watch how they in
turn have they interact in their
everyday lives it's why do people eat
like why do people sleep like why do
people desire things like like why do
you do what you do I just wholly new to
humanity with no no real clue here and
the response of Peter is man I don't
really know I mean we do it just because
we do it you know but like people people
respond to me differently when I'm
spider-man because one they don't know
I'm spider-man and two spider-man is a
hero and they kind of they kind of
cherish that but at the same time he's
like look if what you're looking to
understand is essentially the meaning of
life and all that you need to go talk to
Reed Richards right because he's super
smart and around that's
on the Beyonder has to go to the
bathroom for the first time so peter
parker's like just go right in there man
just don't blow it up make sure you
spray dude and so at that moment what
you do is you basically switch over to
the Fantastic Four kind of in the midst
of this whole conflict we're really kind
of the aftermath of this conflict with
malice and then in turn like you know
the Beyonder shows up to Reed Richards
and it's just kind of like you know I
desire to understand things like I
desire to know things now Reed it
doesn't really panic the way you would
expect him to well you kind of look at
reading you're kind of like okay so this
guy would be like oh my god the
beyonders here you know and kind of
start to freak out but having more or
less been warned of what was coming by
Captain America and and so on then he
basically says okay you know I would
love to teach you and explain to you but
I don't know if I can fully explain like
the intricacies of the universe to you
as to the Beyonder is like okay that's
enough gone and then basically takes off
then he basically ends up bailing out
from that point he ends up you know
coming across some kind of a you know a
suit inside a department store and
basically takes a suit puts it on
himself and then he runs into an old
homeless woman and this is one of the
coolest things right because she's just
sort of like okay look you've won you
can't steal stuff from people like that
so she kind of starts to provide these
sort of societal guidelines on what a
person can and can't do and then to
she's kind of like if you're gonna do
this like you got to make yourself look
presentable right I mean you gotta wear
shoes and different things along those
lines you know and it's kind of funny
because he's like well how does like why
do people do what they do like like how
do things work here and she basically
says like like money is essentially the
one thing that matters most in this
world right it's the one thing that
people prized above pretty much
everything else and it's what makes the
world go round
right like the only way you can really
get anywhere in this world is to have
money right and then you kind of ask the
question like you know the the small
little creatures you know who share your
clothing do they pay for their shelter
she's like what the bugs no they don't
pay for shelter the Flies are free but
it's kind of crazy because what did
beyonder experiences for the first time
is being mugged right in the others
these guys that show up that basically
think that he's super wealthy and
instead of helping them understand their
place in the bigger picture or like why
be them out of existence or something
like that
he's just kind of like you know for him
it doesn't really matter right because
I'm he's super omnipotent insanely
powerful he fixes itself like that you
know and that's basically it but then
from there she basically pulls out a
card and says here's Heroes for Hire you
should go look into them you know maybe
they can give you some kind of
experience or something like that and of
course he ends up jumping there now this
is where you start to get these
interesting displays of the beyonders
power right because it's one thing to
heal yourself we've seen Wolverine do
that all the time we see Deadpool do
that not that at the time the story's
written Deadpool doesn't exist but once
he does pop up
you see Deadpool heal himself you see
that kind of thing all the time one of
the cool displays that goes on here is
that Wiggy shows up in the Office of
Heroes for Hire he realizes that Luke
Cage and iron fist were here but they're
currently not here right now so what he
does is he snatches them out of time and
brings them to this current location and
then a fight breaks out Luke Cage is
like I'm gonna kill this man I'll beat
this man with an itch of his life you
know and they they both need Oh kind of
get into a conflict with each other but
Danny ran ends up being the one to kind
of jump in and try to talk reason here
but it's a funny thing because Danny
rands like look man if you're looking
for experienced man like I can help you
kind of get the experience you're
looking for I can direct you where you
need to go actually just kind of like
building yourself a girl man and you'll
you'll experience a lot if you do that
but ultimately Luke Cage is one that
kind of comes in and says the same thing
that the old homeless woman said money
is what matters in this world money is
what gets you the services of Heroes for
Hire money is what gets you a place to
live is what gets you food all that kind
of stuff somebody's always got of hit
right that's kind of way that works and
so ultimately the Beyonder walks up to
the building of Luke Cage and one of the
coolest displays of power and then
rematerialized is the whole thing and
turns the whole building into gold now
of course it ends up collapsing under
its own weight but it's a cool sight to
see
Libbie honors like I had your services
you help me with something therefore I
have to pay so I turned this building
into gold right again just kind of doing
things that seem to be arbitrary I
understand this is how the world is
supposed to work therefore I'm going to
conduct myself in this way and so what
you end up doing is running into
probably one of the more interesting
aspects of the story when the Beyonder
gets hookers right because what he is of
doing is making his way you know down
the road and then comes across this this
one hooker who's just kind of standing
there and like she's just sort of like
hey are you looking for some kind of
company or something like that but he's
like I mean I guess you know like I am
from beyond you know I I guess that's
what I'm looking for like I just seek to
understand so she's like well you got to
give us some money first so he produces
a bar gold in his hand and then she kind
of freaks out right she's like do this
there's no way that's real that's got to
be fake so she's like you need to go to
like some kind of a hotel and just chill
right so he ends up going like this
super seedy hotel right like the
seediest of seedy hotels and then when
that happens like he's basically
confronted by tutsi who is this chick by
twits is what they refer to harassed by
her pimp and then the guy who runs the
whole show and what he basically says is
hey look man like our friend introduced
us and showed us this bar of gold that
you created so like let's talk you know
this list let's talk unless converse and
let's let's hang out with each other and
so basically this guy mr. Corvo leaves a
Beyonder in the
tuts you know basically this hooker and
in the next morning she takes him around
town it starts to show him all these
different things right to help him
understand what it means to eat right to
understand food different things like
that why people do what they do and it's
kind of funny because he initially goes
to get a drink and just goes to eat the
whole thing and she's like no no don't
do that like whatever you eat just like
eat the food off the fork but don't eat
the fork the funny thing is that core
vote comes along and brings like a whole
bunch of girls right something like like
how many girls are here one two three
four five six chicks right six chicks
and twits is like dude I could have
taught in this whole thing by himself
right like the guy needs experience I
could have given him the experience you
know but like at the end of the day mr.
Korbell I was like yeah but like with
six girls he's gonna get more experience
right because like six different smiles
so it's like okay and then like Corbeau
starts doing these these things that are
kind of questionable but not terrible I
mean he's using the Beyonder to produce
like huge amounts of gold to intimidate
opposition different things like that
but then it's also stuff to like cheer
his son's dyslexia and probably one of
the crappiest things to make his wife
look beautiful I'm like look man she's
your wife you're supposed to love her no
matter what
right so it's kind of like all right but
at the end of the day he also introduces
them to the idea that just because you
can use your powers doesn't necessarily
mean you should this really comes in the
form of gambling debt for Corbeau part
of the fun is just seeing if he can
actually win right because the Beyonder
uses his powers to ensure that the horse
that Corbeau bet on actually does win
but it's one of these things where Clara
bows like sometimes the fun of this is
the luck of the drop not knowing what's
gonna happen right like that's part of
the experience that's part of the
enjoyment is just sort of doing things
and kind of getting a feel for things
and so ultimately after a passage of
about a day or so Cabo's like look man I
can't teach you anything anymore you got
to get out there in the world and you
got to make your own way so from there
the Beyonder started going through all
these different experiences he's like
getting you know ends up getting like
this great big huge yacht he's
surrounded by all these different women
and things like that
he basically ends up running up on the
kingpin and it's just like you and all
the men around you work for me and
starts using his power to essentially
dominate the Wills of everybody around
the world and they all been to what it
is that he wants then it starts to
extrapolate out well if I can control
the Wills of people then I can control
the Wills of matter I can control the
Wills of molecules and subatomic matter
and so on and so forth there's nothing
that I cannot do right so kind of coming
to this rapid recollection that he can
do pretty much anything he wants to but
the downside to this is that as this
goes on he begins to realize that with
the wills of other people by taking
their will over also comes
kind of removal of individualism what
makes them unique what makes them
interesting that begins to go away and
instead he's surrounded by people where
they're all like yes sir I'll do
whatever you want me to sir and that's
that's born right nobody wants a yes-man
nobody wants anybody who will lick your
boots and so he ends up coming upon -
it's basically fixes her memory it
removes the fact that he can control her
mind and then we learned that she
basically found honest work right she
kind of went forward and was like hey
looked like you know I have a job as a
server but I'm basically you know do my
own thing now oh yeah I'm out there
working and while I kind of get stuff
and it's cool and so ultimately he ends
up realizing the necessity and the value
of individualism and then ultimately
cast aside his powers right counting
allows people to control themselves yet
again last people to sort of regain
their own individualism and go from
there and so at that point you end up
jumping over to him basically
encountering this woman who's really
kind of gets entered to be this there's
not really a debutante but exceedingly
popular in terms of the role she plays
in society the socialite extracting Lee
beautiful so on and so forth and when
they have this conversation she's kind
of like you are fantastic like you
please me in ways I never imagined
before and and and so on and so forth
and so it's kind of like he basically
ends up spending the night with her and
then just least right now she's head
over heels for this guy and so he's kind
of looking around at the world as it
exists and says there's so much
dissatisfaction in this life that people
live there's so much unhappiness here
like people are looking to become
something better than looking to belong
somewhere but at the same time they're
all individual they all have their own
distinct personalities and different
things like that this inevitably leads
to clash so it's just kind of analyzing
all these different facets and all these
different types of people and and so on
and so forth and so ultimately ends up
revisiting Owen Reese and so what he
asks Owen Reese here is I desire love
right I desire to understand what is
love baby don't hurt me I desire to
understand love what is affection I
don't really understand this mo and
Reese is kind of like man that's a tough
one I can't really explain love to you
all I can really tell you is it love is
one of these things where you care about
a person on a level that's far deeper
than I hope they're okay right it goes
far deeper than that it's one of these
things where they accept you for who you
are you accept them for who they are
though two of you work to make the other
better but the more that you give the
more of it you give back it's a very
difficult concept to explain love like
what's the definition of love and you
could probably find a Webster's
definition you know out there somewhere
but still you know a person-by-person
experience-based
definition of love depends on who you're
talking to so when he is of traveling
back to Sharon this this you know
socialite here's a finding out does she
took me off herself you know when the
Beyonder took off because she felt like
she'd never be able to find anybody
better than him they said what he ends
up doing is basically resurrecting her
from the dead and then in turn and then
probably one of those one of the
crappiest things ever like he's like I
brought you back to life or she's like
oh my god you came back to me he's like
yeah but like you know I want to find
real love like I don't want what you
have right like the only reason why you
love me is because of how I make you
feel right that's the only reason why
you love me you don't really love me you
love the way that I make you feel I just
happen to be a part of that what I
desire is a good woman so like he shows
her all these different women and men
and it's like show me which one I should
fall in love with which is really kind
of crappy going to a person who's in
love with you and saying here are the
people that I'm interested in which one
do you think I should date right like if
the friendzone basically and so you get
one of these interesting moments where
he's kind of like okay so the person
that I desire to be in love with is
basically Allison Blair Dazzler and then
he also comments she may very well be
one of the most powerful people to walk
this world which is an interesting thing
although we're never really given a
full-on explanation why instead what he
does is he grabs Alice and he grabs
Dazzler snatches her away and then
basically starts taking her from place
to place you know kind of bounces are
all over these different locations
trying to impress her takes her out into
space to different parts of the galaxy
all in a way to kind of demonstrate
here's here's how I feel about you you
know I really really like you and here's
all these gifts and all that kind of
stuff the classic mistake right like
really showing more of what he can do as
opposed to more of who he is and so the
result of that is she really kind of
seems to reject him in you know
initially and so he kind of begins to
understand what it is that she's looking
for that she wants to understand who he
is and so he basically teleports the two
of them ought to a mountaintop in Nepal
and they share this really really
intimate moment and initially Allison
Blair is really kind of swept up by it
she's kind of like wow this guy's
amazing like he's taking me everywhere
and he's showing me all these different
things and he's classy and kind and all
that kind of stuff and so he sort of
like hey look I've got bands and I've
got music and all kinds of things that
you can use in order to keep yourself
happy I'll be right back so he basically
just kind of teleports away he goes to
Alpha Flight I don't really know why and
like takes the bag of shaman which is
like he's disease is really crappy
character and like like freezes daughter
which I don't know why it matters like
nobody cares it's not the flight so the
result is that they're really kind of
the big takeaway from this is he takes a
ring out of the bag and then basically
ends up running back to Alice and Blair
with the intention to propose to or at
least to present kind of a trinket a
sign of his affection but ultimately she
ends up rejecting him and the reason why
is because one she doesn't really know
him and two there doesn't really seem to
be much to him and that's kind of the
big important takeaway from
like having substance having something
to offer right because when it comes to
relationships and it comes to courting
people it really is marketing one-on-one
you have to find an answer to the
question why are you a person worth
dating right like being a man or a woman
is not good enough right like I'm a guy
that's why you should date me it's like
no I guess that's not really good enough
right like that's not okay like be
someone worth dating and that's kind of
where the Beyonder that's kind of what
he latched right because he seems to
kind of like that human component that
ability to understand and relate to
people and so because of that of course
he's rejected by Allison Blair and then
in turn you know he tries to sort of get
her back and there's some of the
Avengers appear out of nowhere and when
that happens a fight breaks out between
the Avengers and the Beyonder and
seemingly in the middle of all that they
kind of seem to get the upper hand and
then of course
Dazzler jumps in and is just kind of
like stopped right because the Beyonder
sort of controlling and keeping his
powers under check so he's not really
using them to their to their fullest
extent but when he gets Allison Blair
alone and takes her back to the rock
again he basically says I faked the
whole thing like I faked the whole
scenario so you would understand whether
or not you truly care about me and you
truly miss me right like kind of force
her hand which is sometimes what you
have to do and then the result of that
is that Allison Blair is kind of like
okay let's see where this goes and so
what he does is he gives her cosmic
awareness and it's just way too much for
her to be able to handle or to tolerate
right when that happens like she
basically rejects him right and then
chains up kind of fleeing ultimately
falling down to the ground and dying and
the resident you know the the Beyonder
resurrects her and it kind of puts her
at a mindset where he dominates her will
and she's in love with him but at the
end of the day he took her freewill away
and so giving it back to her it's just
kind of like you know isn't gonna work
out right it's not something that can
actually function here instead she kind
of walked away rejected him and that was
essentially the end of that and so
following that the Beyonder kind of goes
about on his own thing kind of wandering
around and sort of looking at his own
life and so on and so forth and it's
really more of him just kind of
pondering his existence what he can and
can't do what he's capable of coming to
terms with everything that's happened so
far and so ultimately he ends up coming
across a young girl named Tabitha Smith
also known as boom boom and this is boom
booms first appears to Marvel comics
those guys who were curious at the
moment she's like 13 years old she's
exceedingly young but she also comes
from a really really abusive household
and so for those of you guys who were
reading house and powers of X this is
why Tabitha is so cynical about people
like she has this conversation with the
Beyonder where they're talking about the
nature of friends different things like
that and she holds a very nihilistic
view right in the sense that it's
basically meaningless right that friends
no matter what level they are if they
stay with you long enough they'll
eventually leave right like
any friend like if you have a friend
that doesn't leave you for the rest of
their life and they somebody just didn't
live long enough right that's kind of
her a really cynical and nihilistic view
on friendship and the Beyonder rejects
it and this is important because the
Beyonder is not really in a position
worse it's kind of like people are nice
and they do great things you know all
that kind of stuff but he's not really
super cynical either but he's also not
naive he is to a degree but he's gained
a lot of experience over time and so he
understands the difference between a
true truth and a lie and what things can
really be like and how people perceive
things and so on and so forth and so as
a result of that he actually takes off
to his own Beyond realm and really just
sort of hangs out there and uses about
altering the universe and and really
even creating like his own his own
facsimile of Allison Blair inside his
beyond verse but ultimately it's just
not good enough right like it's not
really the same is actually having
Dazzler the woman who can choose who she
wants to be with and having her choose
him right there's a kind of pride that
comes with that right a kind of
satisfaction that comes with that and
that's what He desires he's kind of you
know beginning to sort of home in and
then hit on this idea of desire and so
following that he ends up grabbing a car
coming across tabatha Smith again and
then takes her to Westchester because
she was on her way to try to find the
quote-unquote fictional x-men school
that she wasn't really sure if it
actually existed or not but as soon as
she arrives there she says you know like
like literally Rachel summers freaks out
and she's like it's the Beyonder can am
I like they all immediately brought up
on him and start attacking him and so
the be honored ascends up fleeing right
he doesn't appealing off in a car now
again the Beyonder could have destroyed
them with less than a thought right just
a wave of his hand and that would have
been the end of them remember the
beyonders really wanted to understand
humanity and because Humanity is for the
most part powerless he wants to either
bring himself down to their level or at
the very least go without his powers in
any real sense and just kind of
experience what it means to live missile
the result is a Tabitha Smith is
actually crushed by the idea that the
beyond are really kind of abandoned her
tread is kind of this continuation of
this ideology that people will always
abandon you this and the fact that the
x-men were nothing like what she thought
they were kind of leaves her in a
relatively hopeless state so she kind of
calls out to the beyond her and she's
like look come back you know if you
don't come back I'm gonna set off one of
my bombs and I'm gonna blow myself up
which is kind of crazy and of course the
Beyonder shows up you know before it
goes off he's like you're you're
insanely annoying she's like well I'm 13
years old you know what kind of comes
with the package and I was like look man
if that's what she was willing to do
with 13 years old maybe I should have
left her you know maybe let that run its
natural course but from there what he
ends up doing is basically saying like
I'm tired of this world and his people
on it but almost kinda like this dr.
Manhattan sort of scenario the motor
stations are different but he basically
says we're gonna leave this world and
instead we're gonna go to the world
complex which is basically the
headquarters of the Celestials and this
is when you start getting into the idea
of the cosmic entities and so when he
shows up here because of the fact that
the Celestials really kind of chill
right because when you're a celestial
like when you're a being as old as they
are and you'll be there until the end of
the universe the entire lifespan of
humanity happens like that right half of
them the blink of an eye
and so for them like they may commit a
series of acts and it happens one after
the other after the other after the
other and an exceedingly fast rate in
the same way that you wave your hand and
you tap your foot but for people who
were looking at them it takes eons for
those things to happen right because
they perceive time differently than the
Celestials do and so on and so forth and
so because the Celestials are usually
just kind of sitting around and and
chillin and whatnot there's been this
great big huge tourist trap more or less
has been constructed around them that
people go and they spend money at and em
so on and so forth but what the Beyonder
really hits at here is he starts talking
to Tabitha about his role in the cosmos
and he says ever since he showed up here
all the cosmic entities have been in
panic mode they don't know what to do
they don't know how to respond to him
right because vig hints they can't
destroy him all they can do is try to
figure out what steps they need to take
and that's what all the cosmic entities
are doing Galactus is doing that Eon is
doing that eternity is doing that but
all the cosmic entities are panicking
and they're all trying to figure out
what they're going to do about two
beyond Earth and sort of really kind of
instigate a scenario to show what the
what the Celestials are capable of the
fact that they actually do things the
viana basically shows up and says if you
guys don't come up here and stop me I'm
gonna wipe out the entirety of the
universe and when the when the
Celestials go to make their move he
simply just that's them away with a wave
of his hand and that's really kind of
the end of them of course everything
comes crashing down
Tabitha Smith is horrified of him and of
course he basically ends up taking her
back to the you know back to earth but
following that the Beyonder has this
sort of conflict with the Avengers right
when Tabitha comes back and tells The
Avengers Hey look to be honest here and
like things I think are gonna pop off
the Avengers respond and the Beyonder
basically kind of ceases the conflict
and then basically starts walking off
and the big question is what basically
happens with the Beyonder now right like
understanding his place in the cosmos
understanding the full totality of what
he's capable of and what he can do this
turns into the question what will the
Beyonder do next and that's where the
story begins to get cool right let's for
this well first half is just things
happening they're not really that
interesting the second half is when you
get to like all the cosmic entities
getting involved in like all the cosmic
entities going to only using me like
you're the only one who can
and all that kind of cool stuff so all
the cool aspects that like to be on der
versus the molecule and that all happens
in the second part of the story oh that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
okay I want to give a shout out to Kyle
be David Joseph then john h aj matt in
jeff our john h lean and mean which is
an awesome name jason see austin s
austin a Joey M Steven Z Austin B Adam K
and Genesis 9 16 you remember guys you
could send me messages and I'll run off
whatever your message is at the end of
the video so long there's nothing crazy
but if you want to put a message in
there send me an email Rob at Robert
Jefferson calm and if you're one of
these people who get shout outs then I
will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch it guys
[Music]